today I'm gonna do my Big Sisters makeup
and we've been waiting we've been J to
do this for a year
definitely three years at this point the
video we never knew we wanted but
totally needed I love it it's pretty
good I think it's so good
Kylie Jenner shared a YouTube video of
her giving big sis Kim Kardashian an
everyday glam look using k'kaw beauty
and Kylie cosmetics products and while
Kylie makes it known that she is not
kim's usual makeup artist Jenner based
off the amazing results it wouldn't hurt
if she was I would have really loved it
oh well I'm not good at it so I can but
this sister duo didn't just play with
makeup
they also spilled a lot of tea okay who
do you think your mom likes better I
think she likes you better
I think her own g you know yeah well Kim
has a good reason behind her answer but
the reason I think she likes you better
is because she likes this the same but
if we're being funny no I think here's
the thing like I do when I meet her like
she's like the end and I treat her like
the queen of the world the two also
dished on their first celebrity crushes
who's yours
Oh Taylor Taylor a lot like Shark Boy
yeah he was so cute yeah mine was Johnny
Depp
okay speaking of first Kylie who is a
first-time mama to baby store me
revealed that she could also see herself
having four kids just like Kim I just
don't know when I'd on the timeline to
this and I don't know if I'm gonna have
orchids tomorrow from their 4:30 like 7
years yeah the youngest Genesis also
shared a random fun fact about herself
she's really good at sports
she was on the boys football teams only
flag until they started tackling
everybody and then I was like I'm out of
here
I love trucks I set the record for my
school and the high jump the video also
has a hilarious moment where Kim didn't
hesitate to take an innocent jab at her
sis beauty mogul to beauty mogul but
this is not working hold on this sheep
what does Kylie ended that makeup
session by taking one of Kim's eyelashes
as a souvenir okay this was a souvenir
yeah you're such a hater I'm gonna keep
it as a souvenir McGuire will you take
this lash it's all fun and games but the
sister support is real here last
November Kim told et just how proud she
was of Kylie selling half of her
business for six hundred million dollars
I've known that selling her business was
always in the works for her for a long
time a lot of companies were bidding and
really wanted to buy her brand and so
selling just about half of it was a
decision that she made about a year ago
and you know that she wanted to and so
I'm so proud of her to think in her
early 20s she built a business off of
something that she first was insecure
about and finding confidence and
you know just tapping into that and
figuring out how to make an amazing
product and just being true to herself
and doing what she loves to do that's so
inspiring and so amazing and I'm so
proud of her
[Music]